[Music]
okay everybody i'm really excited today
because
i am joined by ruby rose aka
grace lewis in her newest film s-a-s
red noah notice how you doing today ruby
i'm good how are you
i'm doing great so i absolutely loved
you in this film
you play this badass mercenary and it
really just solidifies you as this like
huge action star now but i'm wondering
is there an area in film or tv you want
to explore
next that you haven't really touched yet
comedy
absolutely okay okay comedy i i did do a
film
just recently uh which is a comedy but
my character isn't
the comedian she's more
but i you know i loved doing pitch
perfect again
i didn't get to play the funny person
but i was in a funny film
and recently i got to play a great role
in a great film so i would love to do
more comedy romance you know rom-coms
uh and and drama as well i mean
everything but comedy's just
i love comedy and i i want to offset all
the
the butt kicking with some laughs
no that's that's really exciting to hear
and i'd love to see you do more comedy
uh
and it's interesting because just in all
these films and genres you already have
done you've played both heroes and
villains
and i'm wondering do you enjoy playing a
hero or a villain more
i i'm always a little impartial to
like which i do like an anti-hero
whereas one of my favorites
i do like a villain although i i still
i'm not sure i've
really played a villain villain yet um
even this role included there's
obviously some villainous traits and
then she's a psychopath
but it's a little more complex than that
i think i think you're more of a villain
a true villain
when you make these decisions and make
choices by choice
it's actually something that you you
have a choice and you make that choice
whereas with grace she's really just
doing her job
um and it's a little different but to
play like a proper
unhinged you know villain i think would
be a lot of fun
yeah that's definitely a great answer
and it's interesting because that's
what's so interesting about this film is
that your character is very complicated
and interesting and i
won't spoil anything but i think people
who want to see you kind of play
something
very kind of grayish will enjoy this um
now i always feel like too you inspired
me to get
some colored tattoos and i love all the
tattoos you have
my question for you is have you ever
found though that tattoos have limited
you
getting certain parts because i know a
lot of actors worry about that having a
bunch of ink like is this going to screw
up my acting correct do you ever worry
about that or does that
hindered you at all well yeah because i
thought i was going to be a rock star
and so i got i'm serious it's awesome i
100
thought i was going to be a rock star
way before an act i mean i wanted
to be an actor but it just seemed like
rock rockstar was going to
happen first and so the tattoos were
just you know that was going to be fine
and then i finally broke into acting and
went well i guess i'm not going to be a
rockstar am i
and uh so sometimes it's difficult we
have to cover them
change them but i'm sure it's i'm sure
it's restricted
people from wanting to put me in a role
because i don't want to deal with the
makeup time um
especially if it's a smaller independent
film but for bigger films they've just
covered them and
uh or we've made them work or we've
hidden them in different ways
awesome so you heard it here first from
the tattoo master herself ruby rose
checker out an sas red notice on demand
this tuesday ruby thank you so much for
joining me and i hope to talk to you in
the future
thank you absolutely